hey are you an Android User if yes stop
scrolling have you considered how secure
your device really is because there's a
hacking method called The Brute print
and it's a game changer this technique
takes advantage of a vulnerability in
the fingerprint sensor of many Android
devices here's how it works hackers
compile a database of potential
fingerprint combinations and then
systematically test them until the
correct one is found the thing is for
many Android devices don't have a limit
on the number of attempts to unlock the
device using a fingerprint that means
hackers can keep trying until they get
it right now before you start panicking
there are some steps you can take to
protect yourself first make sure you're
using strong and unique passwords
secondly enable two-factor
authentication wherever possible and
finally steer clear of suspicious
websites stay protected and stay secure